Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is 219 to David P. You can call the voicemail any
time of day. Any day you want. The egg man,
call the. And this is sort of funny. The egg
man seems to have been convinced by urine drinker
Christopher Key on Tuesday's show. This is funny.
Speaker 10: Hey, I think you are a little bit hard
on Christopher. Okey. Yesterday I drink my urine
seasoned with nesquik powder there. One glass,
two scoops, and that's quick. It's almost like a
chocolaty lemon shake. It's perfect. Unless it's
fresh right out of the spigot, then no seasoning
needed. But it's a really hard trick leaning
back like that. It's called the bubbler. Shalom.
Speaker 1: All right. So the egg man, of course,
is joking, but I have not gotten this sort of
reaction to any interview that we've done
for a really long time. People disgusted,
excited, titillated, unable to stop laughing.
People wrote to me saying they listened to this
during that interview, the Christopher Dickey
interview, while they were driving to work in
the morning and had to pull over from laughter,
particularly when I said I had spotted more as
a manuka honey guy for sweetening the urine
rather than stevia. But anyway, that'll be a
conversation for a different day on sweeteners.
Wild stuff. Without a doubt. We have a fantastic
bonus show for you today. We will talk about Rudy
Giuliani being hit with yet another lawsuit. How
many are there at this point? We also will discuss
Montana becoming the first U.S. state to ban Tik
Tok. And we will talk about the latest revelations
related to Noam Chomsky and Jeffrey Epstein. They
are becoming of concern to many in our audience.
All of those stories and more on the bonus show.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money and everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Join the money making on the bonus
show. Sign up at join Pacman dot com. I will
see you then or tomorrow on the Friday show.